is to do Quantum Leap any good welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
now something you need to know about me
despite what this hairline is saying I
am actually relatively quite young I was
born in the 90s and therefore never
watched the original Quantum Leap so
going into this new series I was
completely blind so wait you've never
seen Quantum Leap
first of all I just want to say how I
really wish I would have seen the
original series and I'm gonna go back
and watch them at some point the entire
premise of this show has all the
Hallmarks of a fantastic science fiction
television show for me and the pros of
the show which involves time travel is
right up my alley I absolutely love time
travel that's why I love Doctor Who I
love back to the future but seriously
you've never seen contouring at all any
more movie that has time travel or
something to do with controlling time I
absolutely love there's another TV show
that I used to watch it's not really
science fiction but there was a show I
used to watch called Bernard's watch and
he used to be able to press a little
stopwatch in stop time I used to love it
and I used to always want to uh be able
to do that I actually have a I have a
fob watch right now so let's see if I
can stop time
don't forget if you're new to the
Channel please like subscribe to hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us and also if you enjoy the content
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit that join button
no
I have done a little bit of research
into what Quantum Loop was and to be
honest the first episode of the new
series the reboot actually does do a
pretty good job of explaining who they
are and actually does link back to the
old series but essentially if you've not
seen it because I haven't there's a
scientist called Sam Beckett who joins
this program to create something to do
with time travel and essentially
he manages to go back in time via a
Quantum Leap where he's then transported
into other people's bodies but he was
stuck in the past as soon as he helps
someone out
um he would then leap into someone else
and then
it would carry on like that for a while
but he never actually returned home in
the new series they've kind of
modernized everything and they try and
work on new algorithms and stuff because
they want to try and see if they can
bring Sam Beckett home but there is a
character called Ben who is now for all
intents and purposes the new Sam Beckett
he's the main character who for whatever
reason I don't quite know yet I've only
seen the first episode he rewrites the
algorithm for their magical AI machine
and jumps into the Quantum Leap machine
it is then transported back in time into
the body of someone who is committing a
crime now his wife appears to him as a
hologram I'm not sure whether the
hologram thing is it's something that
used to happen in the original series or
whether or not that's unique to this
season but I thought that was a really
cool idea the fact that they could still
communicate with the present and get
information to help them with their
mission and the fact that they're using
an AI now to basically predict what
action they need to take in order to
save whoever it is they're trying to
save I have just adequate look at the
wiki and the hologram thing is something
that's in the original season as well so
that's pretty cool so the original
series first aired in 1989 which was
three years before I was born and the
final episode aired in 1993 and the 5th
of May so I wouldn't have even been one
when that ended oh little baby but what
my overall thoughts of the TV show so
far
well what for one it's got time travel
so it's already pretty awesome the
premise of going back in time and saving
people's lives in order to change the
timeline for whatever reason is
interesting I like that kind of
Storytelling but there's also the
mystery element to it now we don't know
why Ben has jumped into the quantum
machine we don't know if he's ever going
to be able to come back out maybe he'll
suffer the same fate as Sam Beckett
maybe he'll never return but also
knowing that a lot of Quantum Leap fans
are going to want Dr sand Beckett to
return
I'm also thinking that all of this is
leading up to a big reveal where he's
going to return the whole mission is to
is to get Sam Beckett back now the actor
who plays Sam Beckett has basically said
he's not going to be in the TV show but
maybe that's a red herring I don't know
the fact that they mention his name at
the very beginning the fact that they
mentioned that they were trying to get
him back and then Ben all of a sudden
adds in this crazy algorithm and then
jumps in unexpectedly it seems like
there's a mission effort it seems like
something is going on and it seems like
that is the only logical conclusion that
they're going to eventually bring Dr Sam
Beckett back that's going to appease the
old fans it's going to link the new fans
to the old story and then they can
basically move on because Sam Beckett
will have come back and he'd be like
well I don't want to do that again and
he's going to leave kind of thing
overall I quite like it it's pretty good
uh it's good science fiction special
effects are pretty good
um there are a few a few points of it
where you can tell it's a green screen
and it looks a little bit bad but the
whole room was like the AI machine and
everything like that it looks pretty
pretty cool if you don't look at it too
hard kind of thing
um yeah the premise is good absolutely
love the first episode and I can't wait
to watch the rest of the season let me
know what you think have you seen
Quantum leave have you seen the first
episode have you seen the second episode
I've already seen the first so let me
know what you think in the comment
section down below and I will see you in
another video
see you later
[Music]